ciao ragazzi ben tornati a nuova puntata
di cucina buttata oggi ho deciso di fare
una ricetta che in realtà dei nemici
fanno già da tanto tempo e che ho sempre
pensato mamma mia con te buona non posso
credere che sia fattibile all'interno
delle proprie dimore è una ricetta che
sempre pensato essere materiale da
ristorante quindi infattibile a casa ma
ho scoperto che non è così
ecco perché ho pensato oggi di fare i
ravioli cinesi con calma
[Musica]
per fare una cosa simile però pensato di
avere qui come due ospiti sto per
vomitare che sono venute mascherino
munite eccola chiuderebbero dio santo
mia reggina giulia che quindi scrive
immunità sei pronta non possiamo
sorridere marito bellissime di maiale e
dall'altro lato della casa all'anno la
linea a sentirmi possiamo parlare questa
cosa so che tu hai paura a dirlo ma a te
mette un po d'ansia il piatto che
facciamo oggi a 7 non ha lo in cina
esistono 2000 tipi di ravioli con
duemila tipi di ingredienti noi faremo
quello classico dal ristorante cinese
cioè quello che conosco io calcolare che
veramente ci sono un sacco cioè per
esempio questo questo questo questo a
questo anche questo o questo o questo o
questo o questo e questo a no questa è
un'altra
ma bando alle ciance e andiamo a
scoprire quali sono gli ingredienti per
fare i ravioli cinesi al vapore per fare
i ravioli cinesi al vapore avremmo
bisogno di farina 00 farina di riso sale
macinato noi usiamo quello di maiale
maiale maiale con salsa di soia salsa
toast cam e permette senza nostri che
questa è l'amara che buona ne abbia mai
lanciato davvero ma è ostrica veramente
c'è un ostrica dentro ma quale che fosse
la salsa barbecue del pesce la vi posso
dire che non gravi la v ti posso dire
che non è particolarmente buona
sei sicura di quello che dici terza erba
cipollina zenzero cipollotto e acqua che
caricava quanta acqua riescono a
trattenere delle mani a meno a milano in
una ciotola e ringrazio tutte le persone
che hanno commentato sotto il mio scorso
video della pizza perché non mi veniva
il termine ciotola mi veniva da dire
bull o insalatiera con qui sotto a bonn
sotto la campana gabra bump ha detto ciò
però andiamo a misurare subito ai nostri
ingredienti per fare la pasta molto
semplice adesso nell'apprendere atleta
di riso giulia quanta liene m 100 grammi
non lo devi viene abbassato se dubbi e
la suggeritrice this a bassa voce e tu
lo devi dire ad alta voce riguardo
quante 20 non si arriva a 100 noi
volevamo esattamente 86 e 2 bene come
sta andando benissimo regista state 85
perché in g buttati sui fornelli
aggiungiamo la farina fino ad arrivare a
ma scusa facciamo 200 così a trattare il
mercato dei nostri che hanno a questo
punto prendiamo la farina e la versiamo
all'interno della ciotola e andiamo ad
aggiungere acqua per 200 qual è il
rapporto tra un secondo vocale della
matematica
diciamo prendiamo 100 ml l'acqua ho
un'idea però mai usato per il momento di
usarlo oggi voglio celebrare la cultura
cinese dell'eleganza voglio essere
elegante in cucina guarda elegante
elegante dirmi che forse non è un
fermaporta è uno strumento reale in
realtà mi aiuta pure a non far aprire
del tutto nella portiera del frigo
infatti la immaginiamo ogni volta a
tutti i ragazzi
di stanza a lugano mio vede che qualcosa
che non va si rendeva aggiunto
ancora lungo
la pallottola di eleganza eleganza sale
qb venezia adesso è troppo appiccicoso
io so che la farina ad essere l'impasto
un po più ruvido quindi aggiungiamo un
po di ragione e di grazia ap lavorazione
dovreste avere una pallina più o meno
così che prendete e lanciate nel
fornello ma un fornendo in realtà potevo
una pellicola trasparente lynggaard hume
leviosa così capirai gli occhi a
qualcuno e chiedete a questo punto
prendete l'impasto e lasciatelo riposare
per 30 minuti mentre fate riposare
l'impasto per 30 minuti invece simon e
sul divano andate a preparare il ripieno
quindi andiamo e ora il ripieno
prendete la terza tagliatela in due e
tagliate la piccola ciak all idea
migliore
[Musica]
questi tendenzialmente andando altri
dati ma mi pesava in una maniera assurda
anche perché dovevo chiuderli e siccome
ci perderò seno o quei soldi per fare le
macchine quello che potevano fare che ci
dice che qui dirgli tantissimo si è un
boato prendiamo il tritato lo buttano
dentro
mamma mia e quindi prendiamo un pochino
diversa già scherziamo sopra col resto
amici farò una frittata coccodrillo 123
con così siamo giù le realtà è la
gialappa's band
manca lo zenzero così ha stelle ok
napoli zenzero appelliamo lo paga non
c'è mettere troppo se morite o meno che
pronunceremo analizza in quel caso
un'azione stato non lo faccia piccolo
piccolo piccolo proprio dire camst
quando sto facendo niente e veloci a
tagliare questo il pianto poi doppia
iniziamo a impastare e vero ma che non è
divertente a me sembra gotta in questo
momento nel quale non ci possiamo
abbracciare immaginate che sia un
fantasma prendervi da dietro a questo
aggiungiamo sale qb poco che centina
salsa di soia salsa di soia quanta gente
che tenne e salsa barbecue di mare ok
devi dirmi più basta ci vuole altra soia
hanno più fame con l'impasto che senti
delizioso ma perché se non usa dal
canada
senti l'odore
degli aromi che sei messo ma sul po
chiuso è tempo di allergie molto
delicato lo sento ora lei
credo che questo sia per permettere
dossetti per cucinare annota annusa il
naso non sai come si potesse cosa di
questa bassa basta mamma mia ragazzi sta
avvenendo è presente nei film horror
quando tu compatti contro una persona
altrettanto creando una persona o di
amia come 6 mag sa bene che è una
persona è un cattivo di caviglia ci
prendiamo un mattarello e il nostro
impasto che aveva lasciato riposare per
30 minuti non è anche qualcosa in più
perché ci abbiamo messo sette anni a
fare tutto quanto creiamo noi abbiamo
fatto più vasto perché in realtà non
c'era venuta st voglia di fare 200 mila
ravioli ma utilizzando le stesse
proporzioni farne molto di più se ne
dobbiamo stendere a questo punto
tagliare tac da karima cosa difficile
dovete prendere l'impasto appiattirlo
vedete tipo tondo ok
e a questo punto grazie a mattarello
fare questa cosa questa parte essere più
alta quindi quello che noi dobbiamo
andare solamente a stendere sono i bordi
quindi sui bordi premiamo ma andando
verso il centro poi allentiamo la
pressione nonostante il nostro male che
però bastare una perfetta schiacciano la
polpetta rotonda d'accordo
grazie io sono simili ma io sono cinese
ma diego ho capito ad un vecchio la
famiglia non è facilissimo per occhio
pero ci prendi la mamma qui è sottile ma
qui in realtà è più spesso chi chatta
conteneva una lira invece io pure non
meno con allievo al volo facciamo gli
altri e torniamo da voi ho finito
l'impasto la vigna mostra love scusa era
troppo pressata al tuo entusiasmo
vai tu perché io sono a mano libera ok
tutto in vicini è come se avessi un
cellulare to you la ballata salita poi
essere vigili comunque ora è al momento
la verità è arrivato il momento di
dimostrare quanto sono cinese iniziamo
[Musica]
aiutato con coppa pasta per avere dei
bordi più lisci perché non sono ancora
così bravo quindi prendo questo faccio
un attimo anatra ok a questo punto
rendono dell'impasto che piazzo qui un
altro po di impastato se non ne posso
farlo anche perciò pronto a questo punto
preghiamo dio per farlo in chi tira in
che tira con quell'indice quell'altro
lenti cecene 2 che non è uno e l'altra
noterete ogni bellissimo capoletto bello
ci riprovo questa volta con meno
ingredienti eccolo qua ora sì che è
bellissimo un'altra chiusura che secondo
me è più nelle corde
buongiorno democratico to see eccolo qui
ragazzi questo santo che diamo questa è
un'altra chiusura ragazzo si chiama
spiega
[Musica]
carina dai questo non è venuto malissimo
sei pronta questo è molto delicata
accusa il tocco quindi le casse per
marco vietata o no no io queste cose
invece sono una ricca subire lo smacco
l'intervallo più sapevo affacci nel caso
se fai qui autentica dico le cose come
camionisti danni a cose o no in con armi
a di gala spiega fitch secondo però
muscolo cardiaco questo anche mascara
certo potevamo vederci video tutorial
bombe
vi faccio rivedere la spiga il mio vasta
lastricano chiuso dentro dentro chiudo e
dentro dentro
chiudo mai che i ricoveri ma prima una
call l'aiuto è dentro è dentro è dentro
chi è dentro è dentro chi è dentro le
procedure
la telecamera per favore questo ma dovrà
ancora questo è più facile cosa
importantissima per andare avanti
noi abbiamo messo intanto l'acqua sul
fuoco dalla vedere sopra cimenteremo
questo che è proprio lui importato da
giulia a casa potete farlo anche con lo
scolapasta di metallo piazzate sopra la
teglia modo che i favori vanno io
finisco quest'ultimo e vi faccio vedere
facciamoci se appena resi conto che si
infila siamo questo qui sopra
sprofonderebbe dentro quindi due
bacchette cinesi piazziamo una due e
questo mi sto respirando pensavo di qua
1 e 2
prendiamo la mezza con molta delicatezza
e la togliamo a questo punto la foglia
diversa con estrema del che stream
licatese andiamo a posizionare di
rimettere i più grossi sotto mettiamo
invece i belli da un'altra parte e tipo
ciao darwin
chiudiamo il coperchio e piazziamo la
soprano e adesso lasciano andare
quanto tempo io non ne ho idea io andrei
un pochino occhio lungo se farebbero è
in questo caso una tenso struttura ma
che parolone alluminio dobbiamo un
pochino tappare il buco leggermente non
a far convogliare più facilmente il
vapore acqueo all'interno di questo
cosino di famosi e questi devono andare
ogni tanto di dieci minuti dieci minuti
dopo una gara tattica su dieci minuti
non credo che debbano pesare occhi le
due sono le 10 1 l'ho messo così bel
problema mia carriera català la favola
della buonanotte cia piccolini e topo
cercano del sollevante che ci dici
abbiamo ottenuto sette minuti in più
perché comunque sono pieni di maiale ma
quindi la domanda
diciassette minuti secondo me si sono
cotti guarda sul chelsea allora facciamo
prova di assaggio ma ne avrà il loro
brutto e ratzinger e non fate parità di
trattamento impegni brutti fatti mangia
prima quello brutto per liberare più
bene e qatar sono cotti ma per farlo ha
bisogno dove ancora più buoni di ridare
al 35 minuti alla ragazza arrivato il
momento dell'assaggio prima di iniziare
però iscrivetevi a questo canale e
metteteci un pollice in su per il quello
che soprattutto se vi farete questa
ricetta taggate ci sono instagram
chiocciola cui è uscita che mi mette
sempre vederle ho visto un sacco di
persone che hanno fatto il pollo allawi
bush durante questa quarantena la torta
pan di stelle e i pancakes giapponesi
inter che ringrazio ancora bene dettare
la ricetta leto ciotti di libera mamma
mia sono dei bolidi sono belli si prende
il più bello avere sia ustionante le
assaggiate pure voi facciamo così avete
bacchette pulite anche le portate siamo
qui ma lotta che lo prendiamo non
possiamo più riposato sul piatto è tutta
una camera sterile 3 forse ancora più
sottile pensavo io stesso brown ancora
più sottile sarebbe meglio mai lui farlo
di una mamma mia
giochi sta impazzendo io o meno non lo
so
sono comunque ragazzi la cosa che io
apprezzo su di questo form non nascondo
sempre dei tuoi panni bianchi e un
format l'attrice legname
vi spiego come faccio questa compatta
una camera me la faccio assaggiare
quello poi noi cediamo martedì con una
nuova puntata abbiamo visto scavo allora
la crisi pronta domanda se questo è il
mio primo raviolo cinese si chiamano
ravioli cinesi che era il mio primo cibo
cinese e dopo forte vent'anni non bagna
cinese bono onesta
devo dire che è buono va detto che vada
bene